[Música]
muchísimas gracias por continuar en la
pantalla de france en 24 y bienvenidos a
5 minutos con en esta oportunidad nos
acompaña
rodrigo gareth el ex director general de
la fundación agenda cero de méxico
encargada de la protección de menores de
edad víctimas de la violencia llegamos a
dialogar sobre el aumento de las
denuncias por pedofilia y pornografía
infantil en este contexto de aislamiento
por la pandemia de coronavirus kovic 19
el señor arias muchísimas gracias por su
presencia en france 24 preguntarle en
primer lugar qué es lo que ha llevado a
este aumento en el año 2020 en mexico y
de cuántos casos se tiene de reporte con
respecto a años anteriores
santiago buenos días muchísimas
muchísimas gracias por el espacio por
supuesto el maltrato infantil la
tendencia es que ha ido un aumento en
los últimos 20 años particularmente en
el 2020 por un tema por un tema de
confinamiento y por supuesto tres son
las razones principales la primera es el
maltrato infantil en cualquiera que sea
el tipo de violencia que se ejerza en
contra de menores
casi siempre es en un contexto familiar
en un contexto del hogar entonces al
estar encerrados en casa al estar en
confinamiento por supuesto que se ha
incrementado particularmente temas como
la violencia sexual infantil han ido han
ido en aumento con relación por ejemplo
al abuso sexual infantil en el 90% de
los casos los menores conocen a la
persona que abusa sexualmente
sexualmente de ellos otra de las razones
bueno pues es la parte emocional y la
parte económica que estamos viviendo a
nivel mundial no las crisis el estrés la
angustia en la pérdida de empleos en las
familias hace que se produzca un
ambiente de muchísima atención y por
supuesto que esto desencadena
desencadena violencia y un tercer factor
particularmente con relación a delitos
por ejemplo
relacionados con la pornografía infantil
o delitos particulares en el tema
cibernético es que los niños las niñas y
los adolescentes tienen más contacto con
internet no el hecho de tener más
parecidos al internet de tomar clases en
línea de estar más tiempo conectados
celulares al autobús a pantallas pues
hace que eso sea más fácil el el estar
teniendo a menores de edad común
como víctimas de ciertos delitos por
supuesto que en méxico particularmente
el tema de la pornografía infantil ha
aumentado en un 73 por ciento no los
casos de este tipo de delitos no tenemos
una cifra oficial porque los delitos
relacionados con niñas niños y
adolescentes tienen una cifra negra muy
muy alta es decir los delitos que no
llegan a denunciarse pues no sabemos de
ese tipo de números y estadísticas pero
por supuesto que ha ido en aumento y
señor interrumpes son todos delitos en
la web y qué tipo de ilícitos se cometen
pues particularmente delitos
relacionados con la pornografía infantil
el uso de redes sociales por ejemplo
hace que sea más fácil el hecho de poder
contactar con niñas niños y adolescentes
y poder pedirles que se graben poder
para pedirles que suban material
videográfico fotografías y que personas
puedan utilizar para para intercambio
con otros de otro tipo de material o
para venta también sin hogar nos quedan
menos de un minuto pero hay una pregunta
que me parece fundamental hacerle que es
cómo prevenir estos ilícitos que deben
saber los padres de familia de los
menores de edad
pues por supuesto estar conscientes de
lo que sucede en casa tener mucha
comunicación con los hijos mucha
confianza en estar pendiente de cómo
utilizan las redes sociales de cómo
utilizan aparatos electrónicos
por supuesto visibilizar este tipo de
este tipo de temas que cada vez son
desafortunadamente más comunes a nivel a
nivel internacional rodrigo ganar
muchísimas gracias por su presencia de
entradas 24 ha sido un placer del lugar
con usted a nuestra audiencia como
siempre les decimos que por favor
continúen cuidando se sigan informando
se en el resto de nuestra programación y
en france 24 punto com
[Música]